avec violaine fera bien sûr bonjour
hélène grosjean pioline à la une de la
presse on en parlait dans le journal ces
révélations de politico qui affirme
qu'un projet de décision de la cour
suprême encore aux discussions a conçu
pendant encore en discussion de la cour
suprême américaine pourrait mettre fin
au droit fédéral à l'avortement dans le
pays nous d'après le site américain une
telle décision aurait tu en effet pour
conséquence de mettre fin à la
protection constitutionnelle fédérale du
droit à l'avortement d'une garantie
vieille de près d'un demi siècle et dont
la disparition permettrait à chaque état
de décider librement d'autoriser de
restreindre ou d'interdire l'avortement
et ce même en cas d'inceste ou de viol
autrement dit la fin d'une décision qui
est extrêmement emblématiques aux états
unis la décision dit glover ce seuil
d'un texte fondamental sur la liberté
des femmes à disposer de leur corps dans
tous les états unis au nom de la
protection du droit à la vie la vie
privée d'après le monde le document
révélé par politico est très frappant
par sa condamnation sans réserve ni
nuance jamais encore formulé en ces
termes de toute l'architecturé juridique
qui a contribué à faire de l'avortement
un droit donc constitutionnel le projet
accusant même la cour suprême de 1973
d'avoir littéralement court circuiter le
processus démocratique je cite en
empêchant un grand nombre d'américains
de se prononcer sur cette question état
par état et il y à ces dernières heures
précisément beaucoup de manifestants
devant la cour suprême américaine pour
tenter de protéger ce droit on y
reviendra les états unis hélène qui
accuse sur un autre sujet la russie de
vouloir annexer dans les jours à venir
les provinces séparatistes de donetsk et
de l'ouest à l'est de l'ukraine il après
le washington post la russie chercheur
est également organisée vers la mi-mai
des référendum pour tenter d'apporter je
cite un vernis démocratique à cette
annexion un projet semblable on s'en
souvient est ce qu'il s'est passé en
crimée en mille en 2014 selon les états
unis un tel scénario aurait pour
objectif l'installation dans ces régions
de dirigeant fidel
ce cours risquent évidemment
d'entraîneur le conflit dans une phase
imprévisible plus explosive encore de
son côté l'union européenne tente de
répliquer à cette invasion russe par un
renforcement des sanctions contre moscou
un nouveau train de mesures devraient
être adoptées dès demain et d'après le
financial times l'allemagne se dit prête
désormais à soutenir un embargo sur le
pétrole russe un synonyme d'end mois de
pour les consommateurs européens d'une
hausse des prix de l'énergie dont le
coût économique sera évidemment
considérable et on en parlait à
l'instant avec christophe dans cette la
guerre en ukraine hélène dont la simple
évocation réussi en tout cas en ces
termes est passible de 15 ans de prison
mais face à la censure du kremlin on le
sait beaucoup de médias russes ont été
contraints de fermer parmi eux le
quotidien à novaïa gazeta dont le
rédacteur en chef qui est co lauréat du
nobel de la paix 2021 s'est entretenu
avec le journal suisse le temps à
l'occasion de la journée mondiale de la
liberté de la presse dans cet entretien
dmitri mouratov affirme que lorsqu'on
parle à poutine des valeurs de
l'occident ça le fait mourir de rire je
le cite que le président russe crois tu
au commerce pas aux valeurs et que dans
ce pays ce pays avait un avenir mais que
beaucoup de ses compatriotes pensent
qu'il n'en a plus la journée mondiale de
la liberté de la presse on y revient en
longueur dans le journal de 9h30 en
france toujours beaucoup de spéculation
hélène sur les négociations toujours en
cours entre la france insoumise le parti
communiste et le parti socialiste pour
parvenir à un accord global en vue des
législatives des 12 et 19 19 juin
prochain d'après l'alliance conclue
dimanche avec les écologistes la france
a soumise le pc lpa serait tout près du
but d'après l'humanité qui évoque déjà
un rassemblement historique si bien
évidemment à se concrétiser
l'histoire avec un an à un grand h
arqués par la marseillaise qui se
demandent si la france s'apprête à
assister au retour du front populaire la
grande coalition des partis de gauche
qui avait gouverné la france de 1936 à
l'ops essaye quant à lui d'envisager
jean luc mélenchon dans le costume de
léon blum figure du socialisme et
président du conseil sous ce front
populaire ou plutôt dans la peau de
jules césar imaginez le patron de la
france insoumise jeu chez sur son trône
triomphant le pouce levé hésitantes à
user de son pouvoir de vie et de mort
sur tous ces malheureux concurrents
rhabiller pour l'été on ne se quittent
pas là-dessus hélène on a évoqué ici il
ya peu de temps police l'équipée sauvage
de deux enfants espagnols de petits bras
qui s'étaient enfuis de leur crèche
sur leurs motos en plastique des
gardiennes fait état ce matin d'une
fugue du même genre cette fois ça se
passe aux pays bas où un petit gars de
quatre ans a réussi à s'emparer de la
clé la voie des clés de la voiture de
ses parents et à s'enfuir à bord du
véhicule après avoir parcouru quelques
mètres a embouti deux voitures le petit
garçon a été retrouvé errant dans les
rues en pyjamas mais tout à fait sains
et saufs tout est bien qui finit bien la
police néerlandaise figurez-vous a
déclaré avec humour avoir découvert à
nouveau max verstappen le champion du
monde 2000 21 de formula et qui se
trouve être d'origine belgo néerlandais
liste dans une histoire ne dit pas
hélène comment un enfant de 4 ans on
peux t'appuyer sur une [__] est
supprimé alors il est super fort il a
des très grandes jambes merci beaucoup
et à demain donc paré directeur